we're going to begin this hour with a
very exciting announcement from Oprah
only on CBS Morning she's revealing her
highly neck she's revealing rather her
next highly anticipated Book Club
selection here's a look
good morning CBS team hey Gail well I'm
happy to be back with you all to tell
you about my latest book club selection
it's called Bittersweet by Susan Kane
Bittersweet you know in a world where
we're all longing to be happier all the
time she talks about in this book how
embracing sorrow embracing sadness is
what eventually leads to us being
happier in our own lives that there is
no really great life without being able
to embrace sadness and happiness
together
Bittersweet and I'm so delighted that
you have Susan Kade in the studio to
talk to today
guess what Oprah we're so happy to have
Susan Kane in the studio Too the full
title of her book The New York Times
bestseller is Bittersweet how sorrow and
longing actually make us whole Kane's
previous book quiet the power of
introverts in a world that can't stop
talking spent eight years on the New
York Times bestseller list and it's
still selling and people are not quiet
about it no Susan welcome thank you so
much and the tape to introduce you Oprah
said you know in life you have to take
the bitter with the sweet and this and
she keeps saying to me that this is a
very unusual book Big Book pick for her
but she thinks it's perfect for the
times when everybody's walking around
feeling like they have to put on the
face how many times do people say how
are you and you go fine without even
thinking about it yeah it's true don't
you think that's true I do that all the
time fine fine without even with without
even really saying well actually I'm not
doing so fine today and you are here to
tell us why
yeah because
bittersweetness is about the fact that
in every Lifetime and in some ways in
every moment there's always going to be
a measure of joy and a measure of sorrow
in our lives and there's a kind of
richer form of happiness that we can get
to by acknowledging that it helps us
realize how precious life is and it
actually connects us more to each other
because if we can actually tell each
other the truth about what we're
experiencing as opposed to just the
presentation of that smile that may or
may not be authentic that's when we
connect you write about sadness as a
kind of connector and I think that's so
true and the message from the culture
though is why are you listening to that
sad music why are you watching that sad
movie right finereal in here you know
how do we get away from that and what's
the problem really with that
the problem is that we're not telling
each other the truth about what it is to
be alive and who we actually are
um and there's also we're not in touch
with our best selves I mean I actually
started researching this because I was
trying to figure out
a kind of mystery of why it is that we
love sad songs the way we do like why do
we listen to Rihanna singing Stay or
Adele singing Someone Like You Why why
do we love it that much you say sadness
of all the emotions is the ultimate
bonding
that's true yes yes there's that
experience you have when you connect
with a friend or maybe a co-worker who's
never opened up to you before and at the
moment that they actually tell you the
truth of what they're experiencing
that's the moment when you get closer
yeah and you make a good point about how
this is not about depression or anxiety
and right that's what you're
experiencing you should go get help it's
about that feeling you described early
on you know when an older person is
watching children play yeah and they're
smiling uh or it's not sorrow that
they're experiencing because they're not
going to be here to see the kids grow up
it's it's Joy at what life is and that
sense of finality is what allows it to
be a Bittersweet beautiful moment yeah I
would actually say you know that moment
when you're watching the child splashing
in the in the rain puddle let's say and
you have tears in your eyes it's a mix
of joy and sorrow you know it's the joy
of how precious that child is it's the
sorrow that you know that child isn't
going to be a child forever and you may
or may not be there at the time that
they grow up but there's something about
understanding that impermanence yes that
heightens the preciousness so much yeah
and you write something that captures
that you said this idea of transforming
pain into creativity Transcendence and
love is the heart of the book and
embracing this sadness can make us
better people yeah oftentimes like Tony
said you get to a certain age and you
start to embrace it because there is a
finale the light at the end of the
tunnel is brighter but you're saying
it's okay at a younger age too to
embrace some of this pain yeah and in
fact that we know that from studies that
older people tend to be more content
yeah angry more forgiving or the rest of
it and until recently we thought it was
just some magical property that came
with aging but it actually has to do
with the fact that older people
understand how impermanent life is yeah
but when younger people understand it
also they get those same benefits of
more forgiving less angry more content
if somebody gave me the example of on
your phone it'll pop up the camera roll
that they send to you that Apple sends
to you yeah and you look at those
pictures and sometimes the memories are
very very um loving and others are like
yeah I did used to date that jerk but it
brings you it is a Bittersweet moment
for a lot of people and you said the
question that all readers should ask
themselves are what are you longing for
I think that is such a good question
it's not what makes you happy it's what
are you longing for yes because in our
culture we think of longing as a kind of
unacceptable emotion yes but in fact
longing is at the heart of all our
spiritual Traditions
um you know whether we're longing for
the Garden of Eden or we're longing for
the place somewhere over the rainbow
there's something in us that understands
that our best selves you know our
unconditional love and um and truth and
Beauty are all they're kind of just
Within Reach but they're just over there
yeah and when we tap into that state of
law longing we get a little bit closer
to our ideal selves yeah we all took the
Bittersweet quiz Nate was a 5.1 Ms King
was a 7.7 and I was an 8.8 which I kind
of saw coming uh you know how did you
see it coming you know I listen to a lot
of sad country music I I I I do like sad
movies when I worked as a writer for the
old Newsweek I used to write the
transition section you know so I think I
had a heightened appreciation for that
finality you're talking about early on
yeah yeah well I'll tell you so I
created that Bittersweet quiz together
with two friends of mine scientists um
David yaden and Scott Barry Kaufman and
we did a whole bunch of studies around
the quiz and we found that people who
score high on the Bittersweet quiz also
have a kind of easy access to states of
awe and wonder and spirituality and
creativity too funny so there you go
thank you who would have thought set her
up for that I knew that was coming on
creativity that describes him Susan
thank you so much congrats regulations
congratulations thank you so much for
having me it's a book that we need at
this particular time it's on sale now
wherever you like to buy your books you
should take the quiz too to see where
you score